♪♪
>> AMERICA'S FENTANYL CRISIS
CONTINUES TO DECIMATE OUR
NATION'S YOUNGEST PEOPLE.
SCHOOLS HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
STOCKPILE NARCAN, THE LIFESAVING
MEDICATION USED TO REVERSE
DEADLY OPIOID OVERDOSES.
THE SHOCKING REASON WHY?
MORE THAN 75% OF ADOLESCENT
OVERDOSE DEATHS LAST YEAR WERE
FROM FENTANYL POISONING.
MARIJUANA USE AMONG CHILDREN HAS
SOARED 250% OVER THE LAST 20
YEARS, SURPASSING ALCOHOL AS A
DRUG OF CHOICE FOR THOSE UNDER
THE AGE OF 18.
OKAY.
WHY DO YOU THINK, GERALDO, THAT
THEY WENT FROM ALCOHOL TO
MARIJUANA?
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOUNG KIDS
NOW, WITH THE THC, SOMETHING
LIKE 250 TIMES STRONGER THAN IT
WAS.
>> I UNDERSTAND HOW
CONTROVERSIAL THIS WILL SOUND,
BUT I BELIEVE THAT ALCOHOL IS
MORE DANGEROUS TO YOUNGSTERS,
PARTICULARLY THAN MARIJUANA IS.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE --
>> NO ONE'S DIED FROM POT.
>> EXACTLY.
WHEN YOU SEE THE RAVAGES OF REAL
DRUNKEN ALCOHOLIC, IT IS SO SAD
AND SO PATHETIC.
THERE'S A PHYSIOLOGICAL
DESTRUCTION THAT HAPPENS.
YOU KNOW, FROM THE 1970s, 1974
ON, I WAS A MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION FOR THE
REFORM OF MARIJUANA LAWS.
SO THIS IS GOING BACK NOW ALMOST
50 YEARS.
I THOUGHT WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED LONG AGO.
I'M NOT ADVOCATING MARIJUANA.
I THINK IT SHOULD BE LEGAL.
I THINK THAT ADULTS HAVE TO MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS ABOUT IT.
KIDS WILL BE KIDS.
WHEN YOU SEE WHAT DRUNKEN
DRIVING DOES AS OPPOSED TO
STONER KIDS, I SUBMIT IT IS THE
LESSER OF TWO EVILS.
>> DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT,
JESSE?
>> NO.
LET'S GO THROUGH THE PROS AND
CONS OF SMOKING MARIJUANA.
THE PROS.
FOOD TASTE TASTIERS.
MUSIC SOUNDS BETTER.
NATURE IS MORE IMPRESSIVE.
CONS.
IT KILLS YOUR SPERM.
GIRLS DON'T DIG IT.
THE SCENE ISN'T AS COOL AS
PEOPLE THINK IT IS.
IF YOU'RE AN ATHLETE, IT AFFECTS
YOUR CONDITIONING.
IT STAYS IN YOUR SYSTEM.
IT KILLS YOUR BRAIN.
IT AFFECTS YOUR MEMORY.
AND FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD -- I'VE
NEVER REALLY EXPERIMENTED WITH
THAT STUFF MUCH AT ALL --
>> OH, PLEASE.
>> -- BUT FROM WHAT I'VE HEARD
IT'S NOT THAT GOOD FOR YOU.
>> WHY DO YOU SAY GIRLS DON'T
DIG IT?
>> GIRLS DON'T LIKE THE SCENE.
GIRLS LIKE THE ALCOHOL SCENE.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
THEY DON'T LIKE ALCOHOL?
>> NO.
THEY LIKE ALCOHOL.
THEY LIKE PARTIES WITH ALCOHOL.
THEY DON'T LIKE THE SCENE WITH
THE GUY SMOKING.
IT'S NOT A COOL SCENE FOR THEM.
NOTHING THAT I JUST SAID WAS
WRONG.
>> YEAH, BUT IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> LET HIM GO.
I HAVE A BIGGER PICTURE.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT YOU
THINK OR FEEL ABOUT THE DRUG,
BECAUSE THAT'S JUST YOUR
OPINION.
SOME OF IT COULD BE RIGHT.
SOME OF IT IS WRONG.
I WOULD MAINTAIN THAT MOST OF IT
IS WRONG.
IT DOESN'T MATTER, IT DOESN'T
MATTER.
ALCOHOL HAS BEEN ILLEGAL FOR
PEOPLE UNDER 18 FOREVER.
POT JUST SURPASSED IT.
WE KNOW THAT MAKING SOMETHING
ILLEGAL DOESN'T MATTER IT.
THE GREAT THING ABOUT "THE
FIVE," WE OFFER PRACTICAL
ADVICE.
WE DON'T JUST CONDEMN THINGS, WE
DON'T SAY THIS SHOULD BE BANNED
OR ILLEGAL.
THAT'S NOT FOR US.
LEAVE THAT FOR OTHER SHOWS.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT FENTANYL.
WHAT IS THE SOLUTION FOR THAT?
THE SOLUTION IS WE MAKE IT
ACCEPTABLE AND REASONABLE TO
TAKE OUT THE CARTELS WITH
MILITARY, TURN THE FAKE WAR INTO
AN ACTUAL WAR.
WE'VE INVADED COUNTRIES FOR
LESS.
GRENADA DID NOTHING LIKE WHAT
THESE CARTELS ARE DOING.
WE'RE LOSING 100,000 PEOPLE A
YEAR TO THIS, NOT JUNKIES, BUT
KIDS, NOT BUYING FENTANYL, BUT
BUYING SOMETHING THAT HAS
FENTANYL IN IT.
THAT'S THE DEMAND PIECE.
THE SUPPLY PIECE, THE DESIRE FOR
RECREATIONAL OBLIVION, USING
SUBSTANCES IS UNIVERSAL AND
UNSTOPPABLE.
LAWS WILL NOT CHANGE THAT.
THEY NEVER HAVE.
ALCOHOL JUST GOT THERE FIRST.
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON YOU LIKE
ALCOHOL, NOT POT, BECAUSE
ALCOHOL GOT THERE FIRST.
REMEMBER, THERE WAS PREDICTION.
PROHIBITION.
THERE WILL BE A BLACK MARKET FOR
THOSE DRUGS THAT WILL BE FRAUGHT
WITH RISK AND YOU WILL HAVE A
RUSSIAN ROULETTE ON THE STREET
AND YOUR KIDS, WHO AREN'T BUYING
FENTANYL, THEY MIGHT BE BUYING
OTHER THINGS, YOU'RE PUTTING
THEM AT RISK.
>> OKAY.
75% OF --
>> GREG GAVE ME A GREAT IDEA.
IF YOU WANT TO FRAME THE
CARTELS, WHAT YOU DO IS YOU
PLANT THE SEEDS THAT THEY'RE IN
BED WITH THE RUSSIANS.
THAT'S HOW YOU GET THE U.S.
MILITARY TO GO AFTER THE
CARTELS.
>> 75% OF ANALYSTS AND OVER
DOSES IN 2021 INVOLVE FENTANYL.
I SUSPECT IT'S EVEN MORE THAN
THAT.
I'M NOT SURE THEY DO AUTOPSIES
ON ALL OF THEM, BUT IT COMES
FROM CHINA THROUGH JOE BIDEN'S
OPEN BORDER.
HE SAID YESTERDAY THAT HE'S GOT
MORE IMPORTANT THINGS TO DO THAN
DEAL WITH IT.
>> SO I WAS WAITING, BECAUSE I
THOUGHT I HAD A BIGGER PICTURE
POINT, BUT YOU MADE MY GREAT
POINT ABOUT CHINA AND MY GREAT
POINT ABOUT THE CARTELS.
YOU PUT THOSE TWO TOGETHER.
I LIKE YOUR LIST.
I AGREE THAT GIRLS ARE NOT INTO
THAT SCENE.
>> THANK YOU.
BUT THAT'S AN OPINION.
>> OKAY, FINE.
>> YOU'RE HANGING AROUND WITH
THE WRONG GIRLS.
>> EVEN IF IT'S TRUE, SO WHAT.
>> NARCAN SHOULD BE AT SCHOOLS.
>> AMEN.
>> IT SHOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
PEOPLE SO THEY CAN HELP PROTECT
THEIR LOVED ONES IF THEY NEED
IT.
THERE'S SOME -- SLEEPWALKING
THROUGH A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN THE
WORLD RIGHT NOW, AND ONE OF THEM
IS THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE 1 IN 5
YOUTH HAVING SUICIDAL THOUGHTS.
WE THINK ABOUT THE LOCKDOWNS.
THERE'S A DIRECT CORRELATION
BETWEEN -- YOU CAN SEE IT.
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH WENT DOWN.
THEY'RE NOT SHOWING UP TO
SCHOOL.
PROFESSORS ARE SAYING STUDENTS
AREN'T SHOWING UP.
IF YOU DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE,
YOU'RE NOT SHOWING UP TO YOUR
JOB.
THE OVERDOSES ARE UP, LIFESPANS
ARE DOWN, AND CHURN ATTENDANCE
IS DOWN, AND CRIME IS UP.
WE COULD GO AFTER CHINA TO GET
RID OF THE CARTELS, HAVING THE
ABILITY TO GET FENTANYL INTO OUR
SYSTEMS.
>> YOU JUST REMINDED ME OF
ANOTHER GREAT POINT.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE NARCAN
AT SCHOOLS, WHY NOT HAVE GUNS?
IF NARCANS CAN SAVE LIVES, A
PERSON WITH A GUN TO SAVE LIVES.
>> 27 STATES HAVE PASSED LAWS
ALLOWING FOR NARCAN IN THE
SCHOOLS BETWEEN KINDERGARTEN AND
12th GRADE.
THEY ACTUALLY NEED TO PASS A LAW
TO GET THAT NARCAN IN THOSE
SCHOOLS.
>> YOU'RE FOR IT, RIGHT?
>> YEAH.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I PROVIDED IT TO C